SPEAKER 1:
Representative government
requires a society separate
from the government big enough
to control that great power.
So we said in the
Declaration of Independence
that the King was
suspending the legislature
and wouldn't let them
elect another one, right?
Elect another one-- the
representatives of the people
are not meeting.
You see, consent gives
rise to representation.
Now, why would that make for
a control on the government?
SPEAKER 2: Because
the government
doesn't receive its
legitimacy without the consent
of the governed.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
And it isn't even
abstract, right?
Government is a monopoly.
If it's true, as we said
before, that politics
is natural to the human
being, that they always
live under laws, then it
arises from their gift
of speech, which is the
classical argument and also
the founders' argument
about government.
Then there's always going
to be government, right?
And you're going to
be in the government.
And it's going to have
a monopoly on force.
On the other hand, it
can't really do anything
unless you say it can.
And that's not the king's idea.
The king's idea is you're
going to have to have kings.
It's in the order of nature.
I was born to this.
I'm going to be the darn king.
And you're going
to be the people,
and I'm supposed to
take care of you,
and you're supposed
to do what I say.
And that's not grounded in the
consent of either one of us.
We have this nation.
We're stuck with it.
Once you change
that and you say,
the government can really only
do what you say it can do,
that limits it drastically.
And how is the
government established?
What's the first step
in the establishment
of the American government?
SPEAKER 3: Breaking away from
the government we were under.
SPEAKER 1: It happened in the--
yeah, OK, that was good--
we have a code.
It happened in the what?
In the--
SPEAKER 4: Declaration
of Independence.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, we
all got that one right.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
--we get the government, right?
Now we've given consent.
Is that enough?
What else do we need?
SPEAKER 5: Constitution.
SPEAKER 6: Structure.
SPEAKER 1: Right, because
we have to keep giving it.
You have to give consent
to form the government.
But then after that,
do you need more?
Do you need to be saying,
OK, on an ongoing basis?
Because if you do, you're
going to need a constitution.
What was Hitler's
constitution like?
SPEAKER 7: Come and
believe what I say, or die.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
He actually-- I don't expect
you kids to read my books,
so I can quote them.
[LAUGHTER]
Hitler came to power in 1933.
And Hitler wouldn't take
the job unless Hindenburg
and the leaders of the
main political parties
would promise to
support an enabling act,
he called it, that would
liberate the government
to do whatever it wanted to do.
So Hitler's constitution
is Hitler's will.
And that'll work if one person
gets to make all the decisions.
But if a lot of people are
going to make the decision,
you're going to have to
have some form by which they
can indicate authoritatively
what they agree to.
So if you're going to
involve a lot of people
in the government, you're going
to have to have a Constitution.
And do you see why
the Constitution
has to be different from
the things that is actually
in the law?
Because it prescribes
the process by which
the ordinary laws would be made.
It can't be the
same as that, right?
And that is, by the
way, implied right
through the middle of the
Declaration of Independence
when they talked about the king
messing with the government
all the time in the way
that he was doing, you see?
So consent requires
representation.
And representation requires a
written way for that to happen.
If you have a constitution, you
can spread the decisions out
over time.
By having representation,
we've already
said you spread the decisions
out over space, right?
You're going to have
a bigger country,
and everybody can
have a say in it
because they don't have
to go there all the time.
They can all have the same
say in it, but also over time.
Government is by
nature very powerful.
It has a monopoly on power.
It has to be like that.
Representative government
requires a society
separate from the
government, big enough
to control that great power.
SPEAKER 8: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.